[Music]
let's go to eric in salt lake city hey
eric what's going on brother
hey john thanks for taking my call man
it's uh i admit it's been
probably the toughest week and a half of
my life so i'm grateful to be here you
bet man tell me about it what's going on
dude
i uh i was recently
surprised by my wife and i
uh she served me divorce papers
uh man week uh
not this last sunday but the week prior
and uh completely complete surprise
well it's surprising that i i knew we
were having some tough times uh
especially this last year or year and a
half
but i uh
but there was never a conversation had
of that he was reaching that point
and we had just begun
you know about two weeks prior going
working with a therapist on some of this
stuff and so i i was really hopeful
and excited about that process and
looking forward to that and so the i
guess the timing was surprising for me
man i'm sorry that's heartbreak and you
all got little ones
uh we do not okay it's just the two of
us we've been married 11 years
11 years man
so what's the last couple of weeks been
like for you obviously it's been hell
man what's it what's it been like
i feel like you know my heart's been
ripped out of my chest man i i
i do not want this divorce to happen she
is
my everything the center of my universe
even though i don't always act like it
yeah
and uh
it's it's
i'm just clinging grasping for some some
way to try and make sense of everything
and it's it's unfortunate that i have
family who are close that is
carrying me right now holding me up
have you talked to her
a little bit it's been limited i've had
a couple conversations with her mostly
logistical stuff but we did have a
chance to meet together briefly with the
you know church leader for example how
was that
is she done done done done
her words were
well the time she served paper she said
she was done done done
during that meeting with my our
ecclesiastical leader
i asked her for the opportunity just to
try working out through that process
with a therapist and she didn't actually
give me an answer at that point and so
uh the answer is i'm not sure i'm
getting some mixed signals yeah i
i know in these kind of moments
especially as you're walking through
just an onslaught of grief
um
you're gonna read the signals that best
fit
the hole in your heart
and um i would let the
divorce papers that she served you ring
loud and clear obviously don't
you know don't give up if that if you
want to stay married and continue to be
kind and treat her with dignity and
respect and love that of course you will
um but also don't imagine a scenario
that may not be real right
yeah would she meet with you one-on-one
at a coffee shop
uh you know i don't know if she would
today but i think if i i do believe that
she would we can get to that point
before all this officially completes
yeah i think you would is that a is that
mythological thinking or fantasy
thinking or is
like if she would meet with you today
what
what would happen between now and a few
weeks from now that would change that
during some of our logistical
conversations we've had i think
logistical meaning you know
budget things and
process right she she she's showing
signs i think of softening
uh you know not not
big grand conversations and a couple
days ago she even
gave me a hug uh because of something
going on and just little
i'd like to think that that would that
she would meet with me to have a
conversation like that okay um but i
admit i i also accept that i am an
emotional role i'm an emotional roller
coaster that's right yeah and so and and
here hear me say
um what i don't want to do is
you're going to look for every sign that
this thing may still have a heartbeat
right
and sometimes we get our signals across
there because she may be finally
breathing for the first time she's been
thinking about this for one year two
years three years and she finally may be
exhaling for the first time
in years and so a hug for her may be
a sense of finality and for you it may
feel like oh so you're telling me
there's a chance right so you can you
can cross each other in the night um
that's why
for your soul and we haven't even got to
the question i just don't even know why
you called but uh i just started talking
but
for your soul
sitting down and saying can we meet
and be
not beating around the bush i think
there's still some
be very clear um
you filed papers and have you had them
we've had some a couple of weeks now to
be working on logistics is there a
chance that we don't go through with
this
and let her speak very clearly and with
the period at the end of that sentence
otherwise you're good it's going to be
this
hanging on weird thing right it's like
being in love with somebody who's on
life support and every day is an up day
and a down day it's going to feel like
this roller coaster and you've got an
opportunity to cut through the middle of
it and if she won't meet with you that's
a great answer right
yeah that's a firm decision answer but i
think if if your marriage is gonna make
it um
having a conversation at the beginning
or not the beginning but here at the
beginning of the end if you will um
is a good way to get some clarity but i
just cut you off man so how can i help
today man i'm so sorry you're going
through this
i appreciate it john and i between us i
am bringing my guts out and working hard
to make sure that uh
if there is a way of salvaging it that
that's my first priority but my the
question i was calling about was my i've
been with my best friend and closest
intimate partner for 11 years
and and the thing i fear the most
is
being
alone again when all this is over yeah
and and and
and being entirely
uh on my own you know economically
spiritually
we're okay we're big you know we've
we've been debt free dave ramsey fans
for a long long time and we've set up a
really amazing life
but just that thought of being alone
without without her in my world just
terrifies me how so the question is how
do i go about
finding a sense of normalcy and learning
to heal and and basically how do i
continue my life after
uh such a long time of being a partner
with somebody and not having that
anymore that's a great question
um
i think the most important thing to do
is to mourn this like a death
we hear about divorce all the time and
it's so common that we forget how brutal
and painful and gut-wrenching it is
for a thousand different reasons you're
in a fortunate situation where your your
finances are fine you know what i mean
there's not kids involved it's and i say
you're fortunate there's there's there's
less layers here
and you're just feeling the emotional oh
my gosh i'm going to wake up and i'm
going to come home to an empty house
foreseeably
you know for the next who right i'm
gonna come to an empty house right and
so it's owning the fact that this is
common and everybody talks about it we
all have friends whose parents got
divorced
you gotta mourn this like a death
right and so
um this is not a
an event this is a process
and healing is gonna look different for
everybody and it's gonna look different
in different seasons for different
people
but for you man knowing i gotta honor
this thing because it's gonna come over
me like i'm out in the middle of the
ocean
right
yeah um
grief will wave over you and it will
feel like i can't breathe and i'm not
gonna be able to i'm gonna drown and
you're not you're not it's gonna feel
like it
and then you're gonna have all sorts of
the shame and the guilt and the
you know what i mean and the failure and
all the stuff you're gonna feel as you
navigate through this and you're gonna
get really pissed off you're gonna be
angry and you're gonna wanna go rage all
those things are gonna be normal part of
this grieving process um but it's
knowing i'm in this for a season this
isn't something i'm going to do in a
couple of weeks then i'm going to be up
and at them does that make sense
yes sir and at the same time you're
going to have to be up and at them
you're going to have to eat you're going
to sleep you're going to take care of
your body you're going to have to be
around other people right um do you have
some people that are going to walk
through this with you you have a group
of guys that are ride or die that you've
had for a while in your life they're
going to be able to come over at 2 am
and bring taco bell and
who are also going to come over 2am and
make sure you're not having your
5th helping a taco bell right you have a
group of guys gonna walk through you
with this
you know i do but it's complicated she
and i have been married so long her
friends are my friends my friends are
hers
and it and it's i'm trying so hard to
respect you know
the boundaries and and and i guess what
my fear is is that by bringing people in
that i'll be betraying her trust because
i certainly have no intention of
throwing her under the bus sure for
anybody so and
those relationships why would you be
betraying her trust tell me about that
well
she she's had a difficult time getting
friends over the years and and my
closest friends because they're around
are the only real friends she has in her
world sure
and what i don't want to happen is for
her to feel like
uh
the world is gathered against her so
eric she
you love this woman
and i take it that she's a good human
being and she made a grown-up decision
yes
right
and my hope is that she made a grown-up
decision she thought it all the way
through from start to finish
and
my hope is that
when she held those papers and
saw you she thought whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
probably not probably not
um
but you can't not have people in your
life especially people who have been
your friends for years and years and
years your go-to people you can't choose
to isolate yourself in this moment
because of some things that maybe it
might be this might be
that's the wrong way to think about it
she's made up grown-up decisions she's
going to have to reach out to her
community you're gonna have to reach out
to yours and if they happen to overlap
they happen to overlap right
what i'm telling you is you cannot do
this by yourself
yep right you can't
you gotta be really intentional about
your life
can i ask you a hard question
i welcome it go for it uh what part of
this do you gotta own
i have a lot to own john tell me about
it
oh man what that's that's a big question
my friend it's uh rattle them off you
got them you've been thinking about them
for the last two months
i've been
i've had i've really dealt with some
significant depression
uh
i've been battling uh
battling honesty issues okay
and being honest with her
um
that includes a lot of empty promises
you know a lot she's heard a hundred
times i'm gonna get i'm gonna admit i'm
gonna i'm gonna get this taken care of
this time and i meant it in the moment i
didn't have the tools or the skills
uh or or
yeah and it didn't follow through okay
and probably most significantly i think
is i'm as i've been meditating lately i
think i've
i may have been emotionally bullying her
uh
unintentionally but i feel i think i've
been smothering her emotionally
uh
for a long time
yeah i think so okay i think so
so and i and
something that she's been trying to
articulate and i just couldn't connect
the dots until i had a friend a family
member holding my feet to fire walked me
through it and i had an aha moment and i
realized how stupid i've been
so
assuming this is over
there's two choices and i i hate to
bifurcate the world like this but i'm
going to you got two choices
can choose to sit in
and stew in
and try to
rewrite
sentences of the past with the period at
the end of them
which does no but any good
or you can take this
as the greatest sign of your life that
now i'm gonna deal with me
that i'm worth not
not living a life of depression under
those heavy heavy blankets and i'm going
to go get healing
that i'm going to learn how to connect
with folks and not drag them around by
their emotions and their hearts
and um i'm also going to find out how to
have peace with the guy in the mirror
because that guy's worth being loved
deeply right
yeah
and choosing to
spend the next two years five years 10
years
not grieving this because you're going
to grieve it you're probably always
going to love this woman right she
sounds like she's pretty special is that
is that fair
the best thing in my universe absolutely
okay
so
you can spend the next 5 10 15 20 years
um mourning this missing her and you
probably will and you may find love
again and you're still gonna have a
thing for her in your heart you always
will
but you can spend 10 or 15 years just
lashing yourself beating yourself up
sentencing yourself to a life of further
misery
or you can say i'm going to be
intentional about my life i'm going to
own the parts i'm going to change my
identity i'm going to do the hard work
i'm going to go see a counselor i've
been saying i'm going to for years i'm
finally going to do it
i'm going to start taking care of my
body i've been saying it for years i'm
finally going to do it
i'm going to be intentional about being
honest with people and telling the truth
for the first time in my life
because i deserve that the people who
love me deserve that
and
some of that is going to start as simple
as
something cheesy that i do every day
which is a gratitude journal which is
getting an index card saying here's what
i can control today
right it's getting teeny tiny little
bits of myself back
and it's a practice and you're going to
do really good for a month you're going
to fall off you're going to get back up
the next day you're going to go again
you're going to go again and you're
going to go again
but listen eric
you're worth being well you're worth not
living a life under that cloud of
depression
and you're worth telling the truth
right is it do you believe me
absolutely okay
this one may be over
i hope it's not man i hope you'll keep
in touch with me i hope you'll reach out
to her and say can we meet just you and
me
and if she says no
obviously you're gonna treat her with
respect and you're gonna honor her
wishes right
if she does
you can tell where you're at and you can
also let her know hey i know i've said
this a million times and i've never
followed through
and this one's going to be different and
by the way here is my
here's my meeting with i mean my my
appointment with a therapist here is my
this and here's my that
um
but more importantly not to try to win
her back or to try to make sure she like
no man get healing for you
and then you can fully plug into
somebody else not through emotional
manipulation not through feeling
manipulation but connected to somebody
of value love somebody of value
somebody wakes up every day trying to
support somebody else somebody's going
to be totally honest because what you
say what you feel what you believe has
value
not because you got to try to hem-haul
around things and there's no chance on
planet earth that she's blameless in
this deal too right so she's gonna have
to own herself also but this is a a
process not an event
you gotta have people and you're gonna
have to mourn this thing you have to
take it seriously
don't race to move on and on those
moments when the when the waves crash
over you
and you can't breathe hang in there
hang in there
you're not gonna drown
you're gonna catch a breath back your
body's gonna resurface
and you're gonna have to have some
people with you and you're gonna go
again you're gonna go again and you're
gonna go again
so sorry going through this eric man um
we'll be thinking about you let us know
how that conversation goes and we're
gonna hold out hope for you
um
and then we're gonna walk alongside you
man so if she says no let us know that
too and holler back after the divorce is
final and we'll walk you through day one
day 10 day 180 and we'll keep going from
there all right i want you to reach out
to somebody today and make sure you've
got somebody that's going to walk with
you through this thanks for the call man